George Clooney is gonna be a dad did you
hear about that yeah he's having twins
weight is a great great man I was lucky
enough to do a film he directed um he
was just he's he's literally like what
you think wish George Clooney was like
he totally is so I the biggest
congratulations to handle as a mom of
two kids they have kids kids er I have
twins everything in that way I'm like
George you that's right Yeah right
that's what people say about George just
like George Clooney he has twins so much
to share with them of this show yeah is
it everything you wanted to be I can
honestly say yes emphatically quickly
yes yes Tim I too very pleased with the
show I'm very proud I don't feel proud
as often as they probably should
sometimes with not good reason sometimes
there's good reason I I mean I should
celebrate things more because I work so
hard on things I should enjoy like so at
this one I I am feeling a lot of pride
which is not my usual go-to I'm on to
the next thing and like worried about
the next thing I feel this is really
fetishes this show and the George
Clooney news I watched the news earlier
and there was nothing about the good
news about George Clooney it was very
different tone coming out of the tube
but something this is good yeah
and if you had the opportunity to all of
you to become a zombie right what would
you guys want to achieve what would you
want to do out there in the world
as a zombie well you you're not gonna
die you can do anything you want go yeah
cuz you are already dead you're already
dead please
I like Sheila would want to eat people
who were maybe you know I think it
offers it freedom to do what you want
I'm not worrying about what other people
think or do I try to avoid the nice
people
mm-hmm I would try to eradicate bad
people that's a good cool if I had to
eat people that is make-believe I don't
have a book and I'm not eating anyone
but if I had to I would be right to
choose yes the right people I went with
the what zombies need to do answer yeah
you weren't like a zombie I feel like
I'd want to travel more spend more time
with my kids we all get to travel and
spend time with our kids
that's normal life there's nothing
sensational istic about you know what if
I were a zombie yeah and stop
auditioning become a zombie audition
audition I'm a zombie zombie you would
have like more skill and sharp focus I
think I would be fearless yeah by the
way and if you get hungry you have a
club so you're it's like fearless like
just acting like we could achieve that
without some extra plain gold and
killing golfers at the same time is a
really fun fantasy anyone right it's a
large community that are very big like
golf so if you couldn't
bread flesh-eating I'm sculpey we you
would find it audience I believe which
always gonna think of golf and season -
you're killing yeah it's like it's a
great place already